Ukraine's ongoing conflict in the east
of the country along with a deep
economic recession have left the
government heavily in debt now any PS
have voted to loan Kiev 1.8 billion
euros you just won one of the biggest
foreign aid packages that European Union
has ever provided to a non-member
country so it is very am not only
symbolical bullied it proves that Europe
can muster itself and fine means in
helping the countries that are want to
be closer to you and they need help
critics of the proposal said the loan
should come with conditions that Ukraine
tackles corruption and the oligarchs
structure there were also concerns that
Kiev needs 40 billion euros to balance
its books and that the EU should not
keep loaning money indefinitely we are
repeating the same mistake we made right
as well as a Greece when we know they
can't never repay the money we are
giving them the money will go on
balancing the Ukrainian government's
budget a year and a half since the
pro-europe Maidan protests in kiev MEP
who voted to show the EU solidarity with
ukraine there'll be a final vote to pass
the proposals at a plenary session on
the twenty-fifth of March
you